in a truly shocking and disturbing move
the Texas Attorney General is demanding
that the state's Health Department
release a list of all transgender people
in the state by asking for a list of
those who have requested changing their
sex on documents this has sparked
outrage among not only the LGBT
community but also their allies people
like me who see it as a blatant attack
on the rights and the privacy of trans
individuals The Washington Post has a
report Texas AG's office sought State
data on trans Texans employees at the
Texas Department of Public Public Safety
in June received a sweeping request from
Republican attorney general Ken Paxton's
office compile a list of individuals who
changed their gender on their Texas
driver's license and other Department
Records during the past two years now
why why does the AG claim they need this
they say we need this list
to defend a state law that requires
people to use bathrooms that correspond
with the gender on their birth
certificate but it's very obvious what
this is this is a thinly veiled attempt
to start generating a list which could
be used to Target it could be used to
harass trans people the Attorney General
is using this pretext of we've got to
defend Law and Order In order to gather
information personal information about
trans people in the state now I
I don't want to be hyperbolic or or a
dystopian here but we should understand
history
and the Wright loves to talk about camps
they say Obama is going to put you in a
FEMA camp Obama or you know they they
talk about camps they're obsessed with
camps and rounding people up and all of
that
we should understand and I'm not saying
that's the direction this is going in
Texas but we should just understand
historically what have been the steps
that are taken before actually putting
people in camps or overtly starting
violent actions against groups of people
like if that's what you were planning to
do what would be on the list of things
that would we would want to watch out
before and this is where history is
actually very important to understand
historically
what you see in the lead up to an
attempt to go after a population whether
it's for discrimination or enslavement
or genocide or whatever right it's a big
spectrum of what one might plan to do
here are some of the steps and you don't
always see all of these incitement of
hatred and violence against a group so
this can include using propaganda to
make people angry at that group look
look at what the right has been doing
when it comes to trans people and
transports and bathrooms and so-called
predators and pedophiles for years now
okay so use propaganda and other tactics
to demonize dehumanize and direct anger
so that hostility goes up and
willingness to do violence goes up
against a particular group of people
that's happening with trans people no
doubt about it economic and social
discrimination so the targeted group
might be denied access to something
could be education could be employment
could be some other resource this leads
to being economically marginalized and
socially marginalized another aspect to
watch out for you sometimes will see
political and uh legal discrimination
the targeted group might be denied some
right could be the right to vote that's
not happening with trans people could be
to hold public office could be just
basic rights that would typically be
protected under the law You could argue
that in some ways the right is out
arguing for that by saying well sexual
orientation or gender identity should
not be a protected class
they don't want it to be uh that's
another aspect and then as things
escalate you might see systematic
violence against a group The targeted
group could be subjected to physical
violence and verbal abuse uh that that
is considered acceptable in society and
of course in crazy you know when things
in instances in history that really get
bad you're talking about rape torture
and other forms of brutality there could
be forced displacement where the
targeted group is removed from their
homes or communities either through
direct violence or through policies and
practices that make it impossible for
them to remain so the big examples of
course you've got the Holocaust you had
Force displacement you had legal
discrimination systematic violence
The Armenian Genocide another example
incitement of hatred and violence
through propaganda economic and social
discrimination political and legal
discrimination systematic violence Force
displacement
um and I think another example that
would be at the top of the list is the
Rwandan Genocide incitement of hatred
and violence through propaganda
absolutely economic and social
discrimination political and legal
discrimination systematic violence Force
displacement so
we're not saying that's the plan of
these right Wingers with trans people if
they got their way but when you start
asking for lists any sensible person is
going to say that's a red flag and the
reason they're citing they need that
list is simply not believable really
scary stuff happening in Texas
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below